Emmit joins us now on the Rich Eisen
show and that I have to say I've known
you a long time I have never felt as
proud of you as I did watching you with
your son and your wife welcoming your
son to the Stanford community but also
it was about how you spoke as a parent
and I want to thank you for that well
you're very welcome thank you guys also
have EJ sitting right here with me so if
you have questions for him you can ask
him as as well but you know this this
life that we live this process of life
that we live is funny how you begin as a
son or daughter of a parents parent or
parents and then you go through this
process of life and life just open up
these opportunities for your children I
got a chance to experience it again
yesterday with EJ as he committed to
Stanford and signed his letter of intent
yesterday and and as a father now versus
being a son then it is completely
different because we spent 17 years for
EJ trying to shake them over them the
same amount of time we spent with jazz
and Reagan and all of us were trying to
shape and mold them for opportunities
such as this and yesterday was was a
proud moment for our family EJ it is for
EJ he's a talk about the process man
it's um I remember I don't know if maybe
two three years ago we were talking
about being a complete running back and
now you've chosen Stanford the whole
process of making the decision I saw you
finally got to eat you got the appetite
back how was it you know very difficult
for me to pick what school to go to
because you know it's a 40-year decision
not a four-year decisions and you know
with that I chose Stanford because of
just the business aspect of it and you
know the football program and what it
has for me but EJ let's just get right
down to brass tacks
you stir in for Rich Eisen on the show
here it's Stanford I mean it's the best
school in the country what was it like
for you to hear and to say out loud I'm
going to Stanford that's that's not
normal you know it's crazy because I
came from a school that helped with
learning differences and no one really
believed that would be in this position
and you know just to be in this position
it's a blessing because not everybody
has a chance to go to the school
especially a kid that went to a school
that I went to a man I I have to ask you
you know I saw the other hats sitting up
there and you know I I heard what you
said about your son going to Stanford
and if you know your son picking
Stanford but if it was I want to know if
you'da said the same thing if it was one
of those other SEC schools would it have
been different if he had chosen what was
the Georgia I am all of those but let me
just say this Marshall and this is my
this is my honest answer if you ask AJ I
did not try to sway him one way or the
other and what I've learned is a parent
love for their child has to expand
beyond my limitations and I have to
humble myself in the process to allow
our children to fly I cannot hold them
back under my own reins and try to keep
them not necessarily just safe but try
to do something selfish for myself or or
something that I believe that I want my
kids to follow I want my kids to follow
the best parts of me and I want them to
get rid of the worst parts of me to make
it the best part of them if he would
have chose another school I told the
other day it doesn't matter you're my
son and you will be my son forever and
I'm gonna love you regardless I just
want you to be happy
and I want you to go and pursue your
dream and I want you to just become the
best person that you possibly can be
period no matter what school it was I
was gonna be behind I think my wife is
gonna be behind him as well I knew we
was gonna be behind him but we just
wanted the best we're here
that's it and it doesn't hurt that it
happens to be one of the best schools in
the country did David Shaw come and do a
house call how does that work tell me
how that rolls when he who comes into
your house well we've had all the
coaches come to the houses we had
Georgia coast coach McGee came in
coach Knox in Florida along with Dan
Mullen and some other Florida Gators as
well
we had Jimbo in the house coach Shaw and
coach coach GU came in along with coach
divita came in they all came to the
hungry by end the hard thing is it's
forged in a relationship with these guys
over the last two and a half three years
when you're speaking with them on the
phone and so forth and when you're
visiting with them on a college and then
they come into your house you get a
chance to embrace them like family and
then all of a sudden you have to pick
one it's not an easy process and it's a
stressful process because as a young 17
year old child who think that they know
exactly what they want to do and
sometimes you're making a moat you want
to make an emotional decision but then
once the emotion fades away and and and
you start to think about the things that
you're you're actually about to do it
becomes very stressful so I understand
exactly what my son was dealing with and
I'm just proud of the simple fact that
he was able to quiet the noise and
settle his spirit and find a place that
I believe is right for him EJ what part
of your game is like your dad's and what
part of your game is very individual how
would you differentiate the two I think
my running game is very similar to my
dad but I think my brother Tildy is way
different my dad wasn't really able to
run routes like I am especially our high
school I don't think his hands were as
good as mine
[Laughter]
other than that I got a lot of telling
you just sit there and shaky here yep
hey I'm proud of that bagman I'm at the
end of the day you got to play with
confidence and you know I had good hands
I didn't have the opportunity to go down
the field I didn't have actually trained
as a wire receiver like he did
he started out training as a wire
receiver here and I rarely if any time
at all ever did any running back drills
the only thing we talked about was
deepens affronts deepens the coverages
man-to-man reason things we talked about
those things obviously we talked about
the route trees and all that kind of
stuff and he went and sought after
coaching that specialized in that
particular area and so he was developed
as a young child growing up in with the
idea that he may play the wide receiver
position I knew he was gonna be able to
run the football that wasn't a question
but developing those other skills has
helped broaden not only his ability in
the game but his respect of other game
as well you know and people know you as
the football player league-leading
rusher you're Hall of Fame dad as well
and I say you know as as myself and
other people looked up to you as a
football player I just think about you
the man you were okay well your son
reaching out to me and asking me my
thoughts about playing the game the way
I played it you know people sometimes
let their egos get in the way and hear
you say that it is it says it's a
testament to what EJ is right now and
what he's going to be because you
understand you notice this game is it's
bigger than you it's bigger than me
there's things out there you can learn
from other people we don't know at all
we're girls like what we've done on the
football field there's other people out
there that can help your kid not man it
says a lot about the kind of the kind of
person you are
well thank you man you know
you've been in it and I don't have any
problem right now I'm telling ETA to
reach out with some folks here and
locally that's better at Stamper right
now and I'm finding these folks out left
and right I mean I went to my
construction off yesterday visit with my
CEO and come to find out my CEO is
mentoring a kid that goes to Stanford
right now and studying to become a
doctor and so I made to connect I'm
making the connects between this young
man and my son and a whole host of other
people that are going to Stanford now
just so he can get familiar with with
folks and go into sample knowing people
as though it's not so daunting once you
get there we can take care of that we
have a bunch of friends over here whose
kids are there and who we have a whole
morality you'll be well taken care of
feeling he's gonna about it EJ what are
you looking forward to most about your
freshman year at Stanford
I'll see just the people that they
surround me with you know just the
students I'm not too worried about the
my teammates because we are gonna grow a
great relationship just but being able
to meet there's all kinds of people from
around the world is gonna be interesting
to me they might want to meet your dad -
there's that I mean that doesn't get in
the way
oh it will be there he's not a friendly
effusive kind of guy it would the
biggest smile on his face but that kind
of gets in the way Amit before we let
you go I would be remiss if I didn't ask
you about the current state of the
Cowboys what are your thoughts on that
and I'm wondering about your thoughts on
Jason Garrett he's been there a long
time and wondering if you feel like
perhaps this is coming to the end end of
the line without the Cowboys head coach
all right
first and foremost I think Jason Garrett
understands that this is a game of wins
and losses you have to win a lot more
than you lose you have to develop some
type of chemistry and some type of
consistency over a period of time he has
been there a number of years and it has
been like a rollercoaster ride up and
down up and down
nothing has been
sustainable put it that way or I haven't
seen us developed a level of consistency
that we all would want to have
although injuries do play a major part
in the success of a team but every team
has to go through the same entire
process and so some teams are blessed to
have guys that are healthy but for me as
a as a flair who wants to grow in the
offense who wants to be able to produce
on a consistent basis weekend and week
out and year in and year out that's what
I look for and I'm not sure I've seen
that enough of our team although last
week they played some of the best ball
that they probably played the entire
season the question is can he put it
back to back and we're at the end of the
season now so we really have to trust
that they gonna have to put it together
back to back even that does happen can
they play consistently in the playoffs
and sustain it those are the things that
I look for when I'm thinking about a
value in that team and how good a team
really can be when I think about the New
England Patriots they've been the most
consistent football team most consistent
organization for the last 15 to 20 years
I'm not seeing anything like it
and it's been amazing to just watch it's
that type of consistency that I look for
and I think about the 49ers when it came
from last year to where they are right
now they've had a great season I'm
looking for them to sustain that
throughout the playoff and sustain that
going in the years to come that's the
expectation but we won't know how the
49ers turn out until next year but far
as my Dallas Cowboys
I'm just looking for consistency and I
have yet to see it hmm what are you
looking for on Christmas what's a good
tradition that you have in the Smith
household what's the give me something
that's a little out of left field that
is all about Christmas for you guys you
know nothing is really out of left field
outside of I lost my mom three years ago
my wife lost her dad c720 seconds last
year so every year for us is almost a
new normal
and this year is not going to be any
different than the last three to four
years but the best thing about Christmas
is send a smile on your children's ages
as they receive gifts that they open up
gifts and be thankful for the
opportunity to even have some of the
gifts that they actually have we
celebrate life we celebrate family and
we enjoy each other's company and I
think Christmas is probably the only
time we get a chance to sit down and
relax and absolutely do nothing I don't
have to work on have to worry about
color no games don't have to worry about
somebody ask me my opinion I look
forward to just just the smiles on their
face and the excitement of Christmas
morning especially when you have a 9 yo
that's out there waiting on Santa Claus
to bring him something PJ already got
his present I think you got a I think
that's the best present you could ask
for from Santa this year between EJ and
my wife my wife celebrated her birthday
on Tuesday he has has the scholarship
offer and letter of intent into Stanford
they both don't have multiple birthday
[Laughter]
you know we have to say thank you your
times he appreciate it man Thank You DJ
thank you for both of you for coming on
and sharing this with us we really
appreciate your time here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app